étaient présents évidemment les préfets
les élus locaux que je remercie vivement
pour leur concours ses remerciements
adressés par le premier ministre aux
élus locaux lors de l'inauguration d'un
nouveau centre de vaccination à tarbes
dans les hautes pyrénées n'ont pas calmé
les ardeurs d'anne hidalgo dans un
entretien au journal du dimanche
la maire de paris tance la logistique du
gouvernement et demande plus de
considération à l'égard des élus locaux
je ne comprends toujours pas le retard à
l'allumage avec les masques et les tests
nous avions rencontré les mêmes
problèmes
aujourd'hui l'inquiétude domine le
gouvernement n'intègre pas la question
logistique pour réussir il faut une
vision stratégique certes mais aussi un
plan logistique avec de telles carences
le débarquement de juin 1944 aurait
échoué
l'état n'est pas capable de faire le
dernier kilomètre nous le savons au lieu
de faire appel à des cabinets privés
comme mckinsey pour réfléchir à la
stratégie et à la logistique comme l'a
décidé le gouvernement
c'est aux élus locaux qu'il faut faire
confiance
le cabinet de conseil américain mckinsey
été sollicité début décembre pour
contribuer à l'accélération de la mise
en oeuvre de la stratégie vaccinale sur
un plan logistique une logistique trop
lente pour certains justifié par jean
castex par la priorité donnée à la
sécurité des vaccins
je tiens le dr d'abord de façon très
sérieuse sérieuse voulons aller vite
nous voulons d'abord faire les choses
dans la sécurité et dans le sérieux il
faut que nous soyons collectivement très
crédible très organisés et apporter
toutes les garanties qu'une vaccination
c'est un acte anodin suppose
concernant les chiffres le gouvernement
promet que le rythme de croisière de la
vaccination en france sera bientôt
atteint le ministre de la santé a par
ailleurs indiqué que le cap des cent
mille personnes vaccinées sera franchi
ce week-end
nous n'avons pas encore atteint
totalement le rythme de croisière des
vaccinations dans notre pays puisque
nous avons vacciné davantage le français
chaque jour mais il hier déjà pas loin
de 40 milles entre 35 et 40 mille
français ont été vaccinés
et la semaine prochaine dans le week-end
la vaccination se poursuit d'ailleurs
exemple ici à tarbes
mais la semaine prochaine le rythme
augmentera encore et vous verrez que
nous serons nous sommes déjà dans la
moyenne journalière des pays européens
et nous nous prendrons évidemment un
rythme plus important encore non pas
pour se dire qu'il faut aller absolument
le plus vite possible mais parce que les
moyens qui sont mis en place le
permettent de manière à protéger un
maximum de français nous passerons donc
probablement le cap symbolique des cent
mille français vaccinés dans le week-end
olivier ferrand a par ailleurs annoncé
l'arrivée lundi des cinquante mille
premières doses du vaccin moderna
comparativement à celui de pfizer
biotech
il est nécessaire d'injecter de doses à
28 jours d'intervalle soit sept de plus
que celui développé par l'alliance
américano allemande
en revanche le produit de l'entreprise
américaine se conserver une température
bien moins contraignantes moins 20
degrés et se conserve décongeler 30
jours contre cinq jours pompe files
heures des caractéristiques permettant
donc un transport plus facile et une
accélération du processus de vaccination
dans l'hexagone